d'enquêté exclusive sur m6 on a appris
que de nombreux sud coréens devaient
avoir recours à la chirurgie esthétique
pour avoir du travail
la dernière tendance c'est d'avoir
recours à la chirurgie esthétique pour
améliorer son apparence et plaire aux
employeurs ici tout est possible comme
se faire injecter du botox dans les
cordes vocales pour avoir une plus belle
voix
pour beaucoup d'habitants passer sur la
table d'opération n'est pas qu'une
simple coquetterie
c'est surtout un facteur d'ascension
sociale assez assez fou quand même
chaque année plus d'un million d'actes
de chirurgie esthétique sont pratiquées
en corée du sud la corée du sud qui est
passé devant le brésil et devant les
états unis en termes de chirurgie
esthétique ils ont détrôné tout le monde
est-ce qu'il faut s'en réjouir je suis
pas certaine de voir passer sous le
bistouri d'un chirurgien pour obtenir un
boulot qu'est ce que vous en pensez
d'amiens moi ça ne me choque pas parce
que je trouve beau ces pratiques sont
profondément ancrés dans l'actualité
vous savez les réseaux sociaux ont lancé
une véritable course vers le physique
parfait et les jeunes et j'ai pu même
tous ceux qui sont sûrs mais là c'est ça
parce que ça on a envie c'est parce
qu'on a besoin pour vous parce qu'on se
dit que si on est officiellement entre
guillemets dans les codes
bah on va obtenir un travail c'est quand
même fou louis mais parce que les
salariés tout le monde est lancé dans
cette course physique parfait et il ya
deux facteurs qui nous influencent ce
sont les personnes qui sont mondialement
connues et qui sont suivis par des
millions de personnes et pour qui sont
élevées au rendement des deux modèles et
pour lesquelles on a envie de ressembler
et ensuite il ya ces filtres aussi vous
avez ces fameux filtre donc nous
permettre d'avoir un fils a d'la damien
vous me parlez de gens qui ont envie de
ressembler à des stars là c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont envie de ressembler à
des stars c'est parce que tout
simplement ils ont envie d'un boulot
mais oui mais parce qu'aujourd'hui ça y
est ça que ça est gangréné entre
guillemets le monde y travaille ça vous
choque pas ça ne choque pas son nez
voire des mois que valérie il était
normal d'avoir un champ de poireaux dans
la bouche en tout cas ça ne choquait
personne
aujourd'hui les jeunes quand vous
regardez ils ont tous des dents
parfaites mais oui mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a recours à
l'orthodontie les les mentalités
évoluent et puis malheureusement ou
heureusement ça dépend de revers quelle
position autant mais en tout cas voilà
le festiblues cette évolution n'est pas
n'est pas choquant de mon accord
moi ça me choque mais ça ne m'étonne pas
parce qu'avoir beaucoup d'études qui ont
prouvé notamment chez les hommes qu'un
homme beau réussit mieux
professionnellement une femme belle par
contre pas du tout un joli satisfaire sa
voix la mise à part dans le milieu de la
télé n'est ce pas valérie va tout à fait
c'est du travail merci dans le milieu du
travail c'est vrai que les hommes beaux
ils y arrivent ne ils sont il inspire
plus confiance selon les études
donc du coup ils ont des dévoila des
meilleurs postes
donc ça m'étonne pas plus que ça
participe en occident c'est laurent est
bien sûr loin dingue
toute cette histoire met fin en fin à
cette hypocrisie générale si valérie
vous avez une troisième oeil ou une
troisième jambe vous ne trouverez pas de
travail c'est ça la réalité donc que
sais je
pardon ça me va choquer une troisième
jambe et tout va bien à écouter non mais
non à bout d'amiens le pas non plus la
reine est pourri du coup c'est une
difficulté énorme et ils ont raison de
passer à l'acte enfin on est dans la
réalité nue en femme
pardon mais c'est dramatique mais c'est
là le point de départ est dramatique
donc on se dit c'est pas grave il est
dramatique on va quand même essayer d'y
répondre de cette façon répond un
problème avec les nouvelles technologies
vous savez que j'adore les nouvelles
technologies donc ces chirurgiens ces
médecins sont là pour ça il leur semble
la vie tu accordes mettons que c'était à
l'employé de se conformer à une volonté
de l'employeur
alors que l'employeur aurait simplement
regarder le cv long comme ayant droit
même payer ces opérations ça c'est
judicieux
ah oui d'accord loin avec le pot à
droite oui peut-être mais il ya une
réalité et cette réalité elle est
dramatique
l'apparence physique compte quand vous
cherchez un job on écoute sans ombre on
vous regarde c'est une discrimination et
on va peut-être que ce sont des
discriminations qui sont normalement
interdits talon gauche alors c'est la
plus fréquente descrimination et c'est
en même temps la moins dénoncé parce que
c'est très compliqué de dire j'ai pas
été prise parce que j'étais un brain
site immobilier a un peu brouillé en
tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est que quand
vous passez un entretien on vous regarde
à 55% et on vous écoute à 7% terrible
accord donc il vaut mieux être jolie
intelligente et les chiffres donc le
problème c'est que quand tu es poussé à
l'extrême
ça arrive à ça on peut évidemment que le
déplorer mais le problème c'est que
comme on ne peut pas faire autrement on
va être obligé avez vous écouté j'ai un
souvenir assez triste du tout ce que
vous en pensez avec le hashtag sécu dlt
en tout cas certaine s'entraîne chez
elle pour transformer leur corps
un bal a pris 1 c'est le nez qui a pris